thank you to Rocky money and hello fresh
for sponsoring this video more on them
after the reaction
[Music]
peeps how's it going there citizens of
the
reject Nation or should I say citizens
of the reject Nation it's your boy John
here once again doing more Sanders baby
we've been working through some of the
classics now we're going to hop forward
about 10 years in time to the mid 2000s
today we're going to watch click a movie
on know little to nothing about other
than it maybe shares a premise with a
Goosebumps episode I saw at one point in
time but anyway that's beside the point
uh I'm enjoying this man like you know
like I said how have you missed all
these movies we weren't in Adam Sandler
house growing up we weren't a Jim Carrey
house either so that's afforded me this
opportunity to catch up on some of these
and I got to say for whatever aversions
I might have had in the past I'm quite
enjoying this now so uh thank you guys
for watching leave a like for going back
in time or or getting timey wiy at all
as I understand this movie might and as
always be sure to subscribe and hit the
notification Bell so that you're
notified anytime one of these videos
comes your way also big thank you to the
folks over at prepper for chopping down
these highlights helping us out on that
end it's a big task and we appreciate
them for it also if you want to get the
complete click experience in the comfort
of your own home where you can click
your own remote and actually probably
mess it up cuz you have to sync it up
with your own copy but any way you can
do that over at patreon.com theal
rejects we also have a bunch of other
shows and movies with reaction
highlights and watch alongs included
that Greg and I cover over there it's a
good time it's a blast come check it out
te's like these are available at reject
naations shop.com it's one of the best
ways to support the channel and now
without further Ado let's watch the shoe
movie
Click
[Music]
Howard the Duck Sandler also loves his
80s
hits Twinkies helped to pay for
this architectural Graphics huh is that
a subtle detail of his
character oh oh
no what was going
on you were sleeping daddy how can I
sleep with two twinky she's so cute
which one of these turns on a TV oh my
God I had a we had a garage clicker just
like that at the old
place so many things to
click honey I think you just open the
garage the K beckon
sale whatever happened to the good old
days when you pulled a knob and on came
the the old Do's got a universal remote
control one clicker controls everything
makes life a lot easier for old people
like you after you figure out the
complicated ass controls do you think
you'll have time to finish building the
treeh house ever a it's kind of been
halfway done for 2 months now get it
together dad I got a lot of things going
on at work right now but as soon as I'm
done I'm on it I promise I got poor time
management skills but I'm on it look at
Su is duck
oh oh no that's not wrestling that's
less than 5 minutes in man something you
should know about for another 10 to 30
years 10 for you 30 for you well you
know by the time they hit fourth grade
they got the Discovery Channel don't
they we ain't nothing but mammals well
some of us cannibals who cut other
people open like antelopes I'll see you
tonight at the swim me swim I'll be
there okay all right I love you Michael
forever and ever Babe a Mr Newman Kevin
yeah always a pleasure what kind of
stereo you got in that blue piece of
[__] my father's stereo is a bow your
father stereo blows that's too bad
oh I wonder if Bose paid for that one or
if that was just a stray because of the
joke morning Mr hi morning brands have
become a lot more Savvy with comedy you
know in the past 10 20 years stuck in
traffic for an hour and a half when's
the meeting it started already oh no can
I go to the bathroom go to the bathroom
I told you that you don't have to ask me
jeez so Manhattan will allow us Michael
hassle in the hu more on in a red
Lamborghini Park than my spot so Prince
habibu Drive red Lamborghini oh my God
is that Rob Schneider in a makeup Prince
Habi habibu habibu I thought I said that
when Mr Amer explained to me the type of
man you are who prides himself on
originality a disruptor yes I present to
you your restaurant where is where is
bar here's the bar now the waterfall he
is an architect okay make bar longer
okay oh boy cut into the atrium a little
bit no Atrium just make bar longer for
Prince habibu really man of very
particular taste water's got to go
someplace Michael let's just take out
the atrium and run with that whoa this
simply awesome so you want me to design
you an Arabian hoochie house how dare
you compare Prince obu's bikini Hut
restaurant to this hoie house bikini Hut
restaurant Prince habib's Mojo Dojo Casa
house Prince
Hab habba
nowing oh my
God what are the ethics of that scene
see that uh parking garage over there on
56 I build that with my bare hands wants
to knock it down and build a luxury
hotel you got the commission not yet I
just need someone to come up with a
design proposal
intrigued an interesting cut to that
shot intrigued I'm Fourth of July and
with the kids this weekend right when I
get back I'm all over it I'll put
schwartzon on it no no absolutely not
Nick schwartzon can't it just wait 3
days I CU these guys are Japanese I
can't wait for their fish to
[Music]
cook that's why we have sushi impatience
see you later for drinks at happy hour
with Prince ababi my son has a swim meet
tonight that I have to get to uh it's
one of the
go be with your kids Christopher Robin
life is more than just business Corp all
the
[Music]
time what I play they play The Offspring
for like a big bad version that's great
great you're not my dad oh no far as you
know
what really my
dad that was a great delivery from that
kid oh what do you have wikler you just
got here Dad I saw you I mean I just got
here why are you saying that I was I saw
you you jumped in over there you swed
here then what stroke was he doing Dad
he was doing the shut up the shut up
good thing is Daddy was here to see you
finish he didn't see me finish he was
hanging out with pink Boo for some
reason yeah what was that a there kid
was drowning I'm going to let him
drown goes drown into my shot Aon too
Bill hle Ben swim coach must be dad
Michael speed up Michael Norman sorry
don't you lose that Speedo Sam gamg
remember right arm out head turns left
left arm out head turns right I just the
you master that with your power people
going to think you're half a dolphin out
there really yeah he did have a swaave
kind of charm that Sean
Aston oh it's not a race that's a second
one in 5 minutes give me some of them
sprinks boy sprinkle top tier yogurt ice
cream topping everything Michael's been
doing lately is very unhealthy for him
he's going to kill himself Oh no just
working himself into the ground
oh Jesus scared the crap out of me me
too Dad how much longer are you going to
live I'm going to live for 200 years is
that long enough for you and me promise
I promise swear come here I would love
if this movie turns into being about
that how can I live for 200 years show
us some respect you piece of a [__] go
home and watch VH1 old man go home and
watch VH1 what an insult what a burn
what am I holding a quarter Grandma does
not let me eat ice cream because of my
diabetes oh no she says nothing however
about a tasty
qu about some delicious
magic whoa please count to three cuz it
taste terrible one 1 2
oh how would you do that Grandpa a good
magician never Reveals His secret of
course not your daddy has wanted to know
how I've done that trick since he was
your age isn't that true son yeah yeah
yeah sure in a minute Michael who you
talking to I'm talking to my boss M take
it easy even he's got ice cream it's
going to be soup now dude comment below
what's your favorite ice cream and/ or
yogurt topping the goat of all autal
leave it down below you done can we
relax now sorry
oh my God every
time oh [__] you better run
who I hate
that that jump was kind of crazy did he
do that wait for this guy Pocahontas no
back to bed Pocahontas is up we can
paint with all the colors of the wind
tomorrow I have an idea for a pocah I
feel like that's one movie you could
reboot live action you'd have to change
some [__] but it could work besides all
the Woodland creatures will laugh at you
if you collapse trying to put up the
tent this weekend yeah I forgot to tell
you we had a postpone the camping trip
no we have to postpone grown-ups too
it's due Tuesday if I don't finish the
designs I'm off it so but the kids have
been talking about camping with you all
year it's just every choice I make every
I do I disappoint somebody oh I feel
that maybe make sure you don't keep
disappointing the wrong people also fair
I'm working my ass off so my family can
have a better life than I ever dreamed
of having when I was a kid the only way
for that to happen is for me to watch
this sing show so relax hun jeez
jeez are you kidding me will you give me
a break one time the odo's got a stin in
universal remote control we're going to
have one too so it's an interesting way
they have thread that particular you
know piece of the plot into this feels
very tangental but also charmingly so
like it reminds me of all the gadgets
and
Gremlins but if that didn't actually
have much sense Beyond just being there
in the first
place bath be on it is all of a sudden I
just want to go to bed bath and get some
Wendy's fries you guys got any universal
remote controls in there for a shower
curtain or a bath
mat maybe for a blanket you got a remote
for a blanket I'm sorry dude I don't
even work here I'm just waiting for my
friend wow uh actually yeah yes I don't
have any friends will you be my friend
what the hell is happening what an like
Nick swartson has had such an odd career
I feel like but you know Adam Sandler
looks out for his
buds so tired of my
life oh I'm calling it there he fell
asleep this is all a
dream don't even get me started on that
Beyond
section
bed bath must have paid for this too but
this is but I do love that this is the
choice
hey sorry to sneak up on you I just you
guys got a universal remote control back
here go do the Fat Boy Slim dance go do
weapon of choice you're looking for a
universal remote control yeah just one
device to do it all for me make my life
a little easier quicker not so damn
complicated it's like the thesis
statement of the future I'm going to
show you a remote we just got in that's
probably the most advanced piece of
technology we have in this place whoa
sounds sweet it is sweet the latest
greatest universal remote not even on
the market yet Morty got this crazy new
remote Morty we got to watch a lot of TV
we got to we got to flip all the Channel
all all the channels Morty come in the
back with me okay sorry his name tags is
Morty it's either that or a bad Chris
walking
impression about to rock your world yes
let's
[Music]
go I got to be honest with this place
looks bigger from the outside just
kidding bed bath and
Tardis really new
stuff I love the Beyond
section I think maybe there in the
middle he's got great mannerisms in
this sneaky sneaky sneaky where's the
Box does it come with directions not
necessary
point he's always got the dance in him
how much she just think cuz I ain't
exactly thirst and how you know it's not
in the B Code system the B Code system
I'm going to have to just give it to
you you want me to take my shirt off for
you something cuz I don't play for that
team no just drop it why are you doing
this then good guys need a break every
once in a while okay you're like the T
you're like Don knots in Pleasantville
right now why don't you take this remote
instead got a little more o f only one
thing you need to know mhm this item is
not returnable why would I want to
return something I got for
free that's a fair point as they exit
the warehouse from Indiana
Jones get that scissor sipping on some
lean twinky you don't need it you don't
need it man you do need a Yoda though
you do need to name each of the
reputable Brands Under the twinky
Umbrella hey welcome to AR my own TV on
freaking whiz good I guess it's supposed
to speak to his disorganization is he
just neurode Divergent yeah can I ask
you something I mean after you do all
this work and become a big player at
your company would you really think
you're going to have any more time for
us or are things just going to get even
more out of control that is the fairest
Quest first thing I'm going to do is
hire a bunch of idiots just like me to
do all my work so then you me and the
kids can do whatever the hell we want
just got to give me some
time don't give me that look just saying
give me some support sure go to sleep
just think about it Michael
a hey hey hey keep it down dude
everybody's sleeping ah somethings off
with that remote you got to poop again
won you do the humpy pumpy on the duck
okay you just hold it in for 5 minutes
and keep the freaking volume down
oh yes I love that he instinctually
grabbed that and went for the
[Music]
volume that remote does look a little
like a pleasure wand I'm just going to
say it when you combine mass quantities
of cough syrup with yodel you get
acid sure let's go with that let's go
with that theory hey you said you got to
go go already
man all right I'm going I'm
going sniffy long droppings
today sniffy I I'll give it to you
sniffy long droppings is is a good
one that sound effect
Jesus of all the dogs I've ever met I
think I've seen one hump something I've
been a lot of dogs in my life right in
the short run plastic surgery is a
hassle but hey Jennifer coolage too face
and a body that's going to get me to
places where I want to be sure it's
going to get you to the White Lotus I
just think you know they're too Slavic
oh my God morning Michael you're looking
very crappy
today you're looking very
Slavic oh no don't say that you're just
jealous cuz Don and I are going to the
gym all the guys are going to be hitting
on
[Music]
us I haven't heard the in a long time I
love oh my God I want that so bad a
husband that I can kiss and love and and
give juice to oh you got the juice
you've already cheated on three
different husbands with their brothers
you've given enough juice to everybody
next time you fall in love marry their
brother instead all of my husbands all
of them have emotionally abandoned me
that is a drip though that jumpsuit I
had a rabbit named Peppa and that rabbit
abandoned me too you a rabbit oh
[Music]
no oh no you're
Great's picture in picture oh my God the
problem is there'll be contacts or brain
implants to let you do this later on
good Robo dog and he can bark in over
six different languages yeah it's much
cooler than your stupid human dog a see
ke's new robot dog Sundance what the do
very nice very nice very nice it's worth
more than your
car wow not anymore a dog okay now that
that kid's dad's going to come beat the
[__] out of you this is some sort of
reality show are you the host where are
the cameras oh all right America have
you glasses look like ikabog Crane and
sleepy Hol wanted a universal remote
control that remote controls your
Universe just hit menu on the remote no
the menu with the Red Lobster yes on the
remote a lot of Red Lobster shout outs
and Adam Sandler movies too wow welcome
to the construct what is this your life
menu My Life as a commentary yes let's
go who's on it click it click it like
the title this is last Tuesday Michael
was eagerly awaiting the arrival of his
lunch
order who's that James was going to say
recognize that voice instantly Alice had
brought him a cheeseburger instead of a
hamburger as he
requested it's from a totally different
part of Germany it was either going to
be James Earl Jones or Sam or uh uh
Morgan freem
Sam Jackson would be fun but you no he
can hey psychedelic where are we oh
good oh my God you are literally within
your mind Palace spank bank they're
making you like bunny rabbit oh you can
access
this I can't see what happened are you
before
time feels good on my feet check it out
you hit the fast forward button I
believe was some time add to your
conception wow oh my
God where my
mother it's a girl I have no idea what
we're going to do with that scene when
it comes to
YouTube sorry it might be a boy what do
you mean might be what is that wait a
minute maybe that's a that's a that's my
can I see that h that's a tiny
schmeckle think of a time in a place hit
rewind and you're there
um
Place ooh all right we're going to have
a lot of long lenses long takes
everything's going to feel a little docu
style Michael dinner's almost ready
invite your friends if you want to a and
if you want to come by my tent for some
supper or we need at my family's wi bag
and please
company
a some camping trip why can't we camp in
an arv like every other family how can
you get close to Nature in a tin can
like that plus it's more fun to have to
keep each other warm at night don't you
know no cupcakes yet but I'm starving
you know how hungry I am I am so hungry
I could eat this
oh here we
go how the heck did he do the the trick
coin you buy in a magic shop a just
couldn't let him know I knew that oh no
that's a bummer actually that's going to
come back later it's a very powerful
device use it with caution yeah who are
you you know who I am God if you have
any questions call
me no Linda ammer what the
what this is a Tarantino movie now this
hotel project is a big fish you reel it
in for me and it's a Audy
partner Denise just called she's got to
go to rehab again so she can't make it
to the Hamptons Mr Amer if you need
female companionship this weekend my
wife's friend Janine wow you guys should
go to the beach together what she like
Wow Let's just say uh she will eat you
up Sir oh my
God those eyebrows that grin it's kind
of important okay what go to the
bathroom this movie has some very
interesting recurring
jokes dud you suck so bad do not hey Dad
a buddy playing some catch actually
we're playing some drop cuz Ben hasn't
caught one yet you're truly your
Father's
son
hey you're a regular Derek cheer
yourself o doy love you kid love you too
Dad a loving child
abuse your parents they should come for
dinner that sounds good that' be fun for
them to be here for the sleepover God
man it's not going to kill you to eat
dinner with your family sweetie I know I
just got to build an entire model
tonight man I get it but also your
emotions are
incredibly crushed
down this is like Raising Arizona right
now
whoa I can skip
chapters how does this account for
you all right let's get dinner over with
next next oh no alone in my basement at
last should I do my work and become
partner now I think so are you fully
removed from the fatigue of having lived
through all those I have so many
questions can you watch the gang for 10
minutes while I clean up can't you I
just I got so much stuff to do here G
I'm not asking for like a whole day you
don't have to do that much how can deal
with
[Music]
that H this is going to be bad dude also
Everybody Wants to Rule the World skip
the whole not every single oh I skipped
the whole fight
ouch I can't sleep you can't a don't be
upset okay I was a jerk mhm you are a
jerk I mean you are kind of a jerk jerk
you got a lot of pressure on you but
you're kind of a jerk dude stop it sleep
over catch us they ain't going to hear
us come on okay quietly TR Co me in a I
got to get back to work can't we just oh
dude it's the same stuff just think of
last time and you that get into it man
lose yourself in the moment this time
you can be sance and I'll be the duck
yeah but you got to massage me first I
love giving massages you should dog come
on massaging away here
no no you need a therapy remote
dude
wow
[Music]
w we did it well you did oh dude come
yeah I'll get you next time thanks why
have the hottest people in the world be
your wife if this is how you're going to
behave man so we go for tomorrow you
said we could go to lunch tomorrow and
Pikachu dad's birthday gift of course I
I said so so I'll be there need another
massage go away okay no yeah can I talk
to you for a minute isn't Michael Newman
like a new wave musician or something no
that's Gary
new Hello whoa where' you come from you
don't want to
know his delivery throughout this is
like Peak walking but it's it's it's
poetry it's like a dance it must have
been an autopilot that's what happens to
you when you fast forward okay yeah I'll
show you oh sure good he's here for me
the remote lets your mind skip around
but your body actually stays put for all
the boring stuff Hy we should go to
lunch tomorrow got your dead birthday
again sounds
good I'm having conversations on
autopilot then you're not going to be
the life of the py but
yes M your wife absolutely gorgeous
perfect face tight rocking
body I wish Christopher Walkin say that
about me she felt for a schlub like you
sometimes it's better to keep certain
memories just in your head so I've
learned Morty good night thank you I
don't know which I would have preferred
like a bunch of stereotypically hot Adam
Sandler you know partner girls or you
know what we got here it's Monday
already are you kidding me no more FL
ski an entire cold what I don't remember
doing any work this
weekend yeah oh yeah this going to do to
your sweetie there's no hot water I got
to take a shower well you're going to
freeze your bum off boil some some water
in the
stove don't worry dude you're going to
get that like
anti-inflammatory look at me oh showered
and dress and looking sexy oh boy you
going to have to work late again tonight
unfortunately yes is there anything we
can do to help well I'm going to be
partnered soon and I'm going to need a
lot of new building designs so if you
guys have any cool ideas why don't you
draw them up for me
a they're going to design some cool
imaginative building they're going to be
building by the very end of the
[Music]
[Applause]
movie everyone's looking at
you no don't mute Sergeant Jeffords
traffic traffic no more traffic no Terry
yeah that's what I'm talking about
baby you look a little pale there pal
let me fix
that oh no you now all yellow from the
scurvy captain now you're just in a
Michael Bay movie now don't get the Hulk
angry that's it check out Julio e
glacius Julio glaas wait a minute
refresh me chat comments it's actually
pretty good man where'd you find the
time to get a t uh I guess I can do it
all sir you can do it all wow it's
sexual harassment speech Day speech day
anyone can be a victim of sexual
harassment a woman a man what is going
to happen here you see what is sh
here like the day I said you want a
promotion pray God the lotion hilarious
sexual harassment if you ask me of
course
something public
bathroom did they get like I know
they're like famous voice actors in
various parts of the world so did they
get like Adam Sandler and Hasselhoff's
like voiceovers for Spanish language to
do that itro is the greatest of all time
the goat you can always count on
Matsui well if you guys love Ichiro and
Matsui so much let's order them both hey
see you guys in a bit each your own
Match away baseball players
yes oh yeah you can translate these
morons are so boring they make me want
to take a sword and chop my own off wow
Hotel design like to rip it up think
that Egghead watched a bed documentary
on Asian architecture uhoh the lobby
let's build more rooms and maximize
profs eat as fast as you can then we can
get out of here and do jell shots at
America's greatest cultural achievement
TGI Friday TG
Fridays I realize this is not what
you're all about let's just throw it out
all right start from scratch River in
the lobby idea what an egghead move
forget all the niceties and maximize our
Revenue that's what it's all about
anyway oh now you're speaking our
everyone's language that way we can get
the hell out of this dump go to a TGI
Friday do some jello shots to this guy
pukes up a
l
yeah smooth sailan from here on out oh I
got your presents what is it what is it
well if you bring your tushies
downstairs we'll find out oh my goodness
it's almost Charming the the grand
degree of branded references and and
product placed you know props and things
there are it's just part of an Adam
Sandler movie to me
[Music]
now a real Huff bike take them outside
wait theor let him see what you got ouch
ride it through their living room wreck
their carpets and scribble on their
walls oh Michael it's beautiful
a a what are we
celebrating we're healthy we got a great
family are we healthy I'm am's newest
partner you're going to have like a
heart attack with all those cakes that
you eat that's incredible I knew it was
going to be a great day today I heard
her song on the radio this morning a the
song that was playing during our first
kiss oh oh no oh no of course I know our
song our song
is wow I remember this place oh
Wolverine's goofy cousin it's kind of a
nice look though I like it oh my
goodness look at you you're out of his
League aren't you look at those earrings
yo first kiss
time
oh what's going to happen you got an
answer to
that a and I love how the song just kind
of floats
in all she's thinking about is I am not
kissing that beard
[Music]
a I'm such a fool for you
The Cranberries was playing during our
first juicy kiss and my God you look
beautiful in that pink sweat are you
wearing a oh you really knocked one out
of the park last night didn't you hey
you were great too all you got to do now
is draw up the construction plans if wat
commits to the major bulk of the funds
looking at my new partner Oh I thought I
was already your partner whoa Cowboy
yeah I said land the wat sahita account
you'll get promoted I didn't mean right
this second
to do these documents it's going to take
me months and you better get started
oh wow I just got a big headache I hung
out with your friend Janine this weekend
I hope she's doing your brother right
now you bigheaded
buffoon oh my God what are you doing
here what are you doing
here wow that last one came out that
last one came out in your Brites dude
no anyway the you get it back
to pardner rise I taste
[__] consider the consequences of the
thing you're thinking about doing what
are you saying I shouldn't do it it's
your life you do with the remote
decision Micha oh we're talking a couple
of months here I fast forward through it
what am I going to miss uh 30 arguments
in a haircut a m the leprechaun oh one
from the cereal Ed lucky never gets his
Lucky Charms they're magically delicious
de kids are always messing with them was
chasing the pot of gold at the end of
the rainbow but when it gets there it's
just corn
flakes and marshmallows you don't
understand the metaphor I won't do it
all
right oh boy nah you still don't
understand the metaphor though Dad yeah
we have some designs for you maybe
they'll help you finish quicker all
right you want me to look at it oh no oh
no ceilings too high the hallways too
narrow stairway placement makes no sense
at all what the hell is this room made
it
Pizza yes no I want a pizza room he's 7
years old if he wants a playroom made of
pizza then why not maybe he's got to
grow up sometime and get the hell off
Fantasy Island the plane the plane he
make your partner today oh honey I'm so
sorry she's the most understanding
person forward me to my
promotion fast forward to the promotion
the greatest partner I could ever dream
of thank you guys oh you guys have been
dating a couple of months now that's
pretty huge for this
one a now the first few months were easy
it was the one year hump that was the
tough part oh yeah hey hi how's he doing
for you and Donna what do you mean you
know what sweetie it's none of our
business let's let Michael bask in his
glory oh yeah yeah you knew this was
coming no no I want to I want to it's
I'm I'm on autopilot I'm on autopilot
you like Auto Zombie yeah what do you
want from me this is what happens oh my
God he's going to answer his
phone what the heck happened I didn't
even touch the remote great you're going
to startop watching TV at dinner now M
I'm not going to work tonight we're
going to watch Dragon Tales together
what do you say Dragon Tales is for
babies dad I want to watch
CSI but which CSI
like whoa hey better destroy that dog
and get your Twinkie back give me my
twinkie get back here you freaking
Gremlin ah Gremlins great movie where
Sundance don't mention Sundance the kids
just stop crying oh he died no
oh
no Daddy held it in so long he was your
best dog he's finally letting himself
feel
[Laughter]
it he tried to hump my leg and I didn't
let him and I should I'm
sorry it's okay let it out you do you
still love me I don't know to stay with
me my God it didn't take the duck long
to get over Sundance uh deviant but it's
kind of turning me on oh
my no
[Music]
no no my
God no no it's not my fault it jumped on
its own I didn't even hit the button not
even close oh
no oh
no
[Laughter]
this thing is broken it's just it's fast
forward and on its own now it's not a
malfunction it's a feature using its
memory to execute your preferences
advanced piece of equipment like to yes
sir oh it is it's going to do it on its
own now pretty much no more showering no
more traffic no more arguing no sickness
this bad oh yeah deactivating my service
I qu I he said you can't return
it
no
[Music]
whoa nice get away is this a stickup or
are you just
happy this item is non returnable sure
how do I get it to just stop fast
forwarding you got to you got to can you
like break through it you want to shower
first no I can't shower because then
I'll fast forward and if I fast forward
who knows how long I'll fast forward for
let me just uh how's this I'm going to R
it today uh and we can't argue because
off I'll go so I just know there is a
problem I tried to get rid of the
problem last night and it almost ended
up in my ass so wa I can't give you a
kiss because if I give you a kiss it
might lead to something else and then
zip another 3 minutes goes by laying
there disappointed and I'm laying there
like an idiot smiling so I
oh my
[Music]
God a pretty solid soundtrack on this
movie man and we're in New York it's
perfect place for The Strokes your first
day as a partner you come to work in a
freaking bathrobe I just feel we should
stop wasting our energy on corporate
Brown noosing and worrying who's got the
better suit armman Calvin Klein who
cares ex shell white but God damn it
you're right of course you are there's
something or actually someone I'd like
to talk to you about Janine oh Janine
and I have decided to drop out of the
Rat Race slow down and move to Morocco
wow Eric Lamona will assume my
day-to-day responsibilities and I'd like
you to take his job you know I wouldn't
be surprised if one day you ended up
being our CEO if you could just get your
[__] together but no no no no I don't
want a promotion
no oh oh Michael you have a phone
call wow where that big guy wow told me
you wanted to be CEO Eric LOF killed
himself
oh I mean you do got to do something
about your diet man I love sweets as
much as the next person but things
good oh yeah there is some CG and some
makeup and possibly a a whole different
body double happening
here oh my God I'm a fat guy look at
me it's okay oh no not the sounds not
the squirmy jiggle
sounds this is 1010 winds news February
5th 2017 things don't
click oh my can I help
you hey whoa Jonah Hill
look how big you got you're enormous
ouch maybe if you would take me like to
Pilates like you said you would people
wouldn't think I was Rosie o'donell ouch
it is so embarrassing whoa and you get
your ass upstairs you put some normal
clothes on why are you so mean to me get
him on just let her be Js from Arcane
you I'm so scared knock knock gang hey
uhoh oh no Sean
Aston oh I forgot about sha Aston he had
to come back back you cheating on me
with Johnny g string over here I thought
we were past all that no no no we'll
past this all that oh just you don't
mess with another man right you don't
mess with yeah you scking up for him go
away gote
you oh my God this is a nightmare I hate
[Music]
you no and you never ever finish the
That's right The Treehouse 10 years
you're not finished yet
Mor you did this to yourself Michael no
you did this to yourself Michael the
remote goes by your behavior every time
you had a conflict between work and home
work one yeah you can't change what
already happened but you're still a
young man you could win on a back so
that's what I'll do
wow
ow yeah please just read my note I hate
you I hate
you
yeah Michael are you awake Michael honey
oh where did all my fat go is he an
Oldman I mean he doesn't look that old
did a fuzzy dog push me over oh Shaggy
the miracle dog yeah if he hadn't
knocked you on your nogin you wouldn't
have had the CAT scan that found the
cancer before it spread too far wow you
had cancer you're the only person in the
world to gain weight during chemo that's
probably what caused your heart attack
what what since the head injury you
haven't been healthy a full day when
exactly did I hurt my
head six years ago six more years no no
it skipped all my
sickness Bill's waiting for me
downstairs Bill a Bill's my husband
please learn to accept that I really
have to go husbando Dad hey how you
feeling
whoa my old office what what are we
doing here the architect how did this
happen where's your pizza room oh wait
that's a blondie chesty
what check check and check no that's
your daughter Samantha of course it is
always take care of her and make sure
nobody touches her make sure that her
emotional needs are met and the she's
cared for like to spend more time
together all of us take you out for ice
cream how's that you Samantha Grandpa
Grandma oh need to go pop drink this all
right drink some water are Grandma and
Grandpa gone Grandpa died dad oh yeah
yeah oh no where was I you crying what
happened oh you know he just got old
that's life
[Music]
oh man I got to go hey hang on Susie
push my next meeting I'll do your
meeting it's fine I'm just dizzy dizzy
from the operation you're going to make
me cry dad
a yeah it won't take you there take me
where to the moment he died you weren't
there can you take me to the last time I
saw him please oh boy boy would you mind
looking at my uh my shopping mall design
again if you check this out it's got a
pizza room let me do my email yeah
you're right Dad um he ain't right
you're a schmuck surprise whoa theyve
had him in younger and older make up
this
movie when did you get so handsome oh no
is this going to be like an ugly moment
your mother's playing Canter with her
friends tonight I thought oh what a
great opportunity you me and Ben should
go and have a boys night out K oh
you have to eat sometime we could go we
could whistle at pretty
girls hey please don't give me that
finger runs in the family I'll make you
deal if you come oh no yeah I'll show
you the qu you knew this was coming
don't you want to know you do the stupid
trick I've always known can you let me
do my work yeah I'm so sorry I parched
in oh see you later grandpa I love you
it's SC Avengers
[Music]
table oh
dude oh he's yeah take your
opportunity I love you son yeah I love
you too
death that's actually a really Surly
touching
moment h
that's that's sweet I'm sorry about your
father taking him wasn't something I
wanted to do oh what's that what do you
mean taking him an angel M okay of
course I thought an angel's supposed to
protect people I'm the angel of death
woooo that shot your dad is
time oh my God we got
Scrooged all right leave me alone leave
me alone you have your fun just take me
to a good place oh take me to the good
place cuz you know you're going to the
bad place right now it's time for Mr
Newman to say a few words cheeu Christ
day wedding cake okay where's the groom
hi there wow this is terrific buddy
who's the lucky lady very funny Mr
Newman God the drips at this
party
oh congratulations let's have the best
night okay
a Michael you haven't kissed me like
that since you were a little boy you
were the best M A why didn't you say it
soona you've been so generous taking
care of all this in the kids honeymoon
absolutely thank
you here's one you might remember from
The Cranberries oh
no oh no what's it called linger Bill
since it's our son's wedding do you mind
if I dance with my ex-husband for a
minute yeah it's a Mana hey what are you
doing put a sweater on covered them up
jeez it's not used to seeing y'all
growing up like this okay well if that's
your way of telling me that I look
pretty then thank
you doing all the work there I raise you
there dad
come yeah do that stretch Zoom oh no
your
[Music]
heart okay it looks like alucino almost
one dance you pop a artery why did you
make me waste my entire life nah don't
pass the buck live the life you chose
big shot yeah this is not the life I
want looks like it
is oh my God she said she wouldn't leave
the hospital until you woke up why' you
do that or my father Oh I thought bill
was your father I have two fathers it's
like that book they took out of the
school library I've got two dance and I
got a plane to catch going I have to
leave he needs his
wa guys this all h
g who this spongebath going on over
there it doesn't have to end
now
oo did you design this
[Music]
facility future cars I do appreciate how
much they committed to this darker you
know ending
act
[Music]
oh oh my
God oh my God the intensity of the
shot
[Music]
oh
family family comes first family comes
first I love you I love you
[Music]
a is he going to yeah of course till the
very end
you're
[Music]
okay that's very
sweet forever and ever
[Music]
Big
Damn
yeah
called it it it was in the visual
language I can't give myself too much
credit you're in bed bath and beyon next
SW I'm back in the store I'm young
again I'm young you're kind of on the
back nine no ouch I'm just teeing off
baby yeah Happy Gilmore yeah you want a
friend this Spirits did it all in one
night or the
angel my crappy car
sequel to That's my boy that's my crappy
car dude where's my crappy
car what's WR I just want to tell you I
love you I love you so much you got to
tell me how you do the quarter trick
please it's driving me crazy mag never
reveals the secrets come over tomorrow
night and the next night and the next
night and the night after that okay any
you live with us now do you mind I am
trying to concentrate I mean here I am
staying up all night killing myself
trying to come up with activities for
our fourth of July camp a trip but you
won't let me think oh you want time to
think why didn't you think about the
fact you just
W what did you just say if you keep up
this weird attitude I won't be able to
go to work for a year and have to plan
10 more vacations that make you happy
did you eat a bad Yodo you know what I'm
going to finish the Treehouse and we're
going to sleep in it next weekend and
from now on we're going to exercise
together and I'm not going to wear a
Speedo I'm not going to wear a Speedo
doggy ears go by very quick so it's time
to enjoy the real
thing wow wow interesting but but
sure
a no they told me at the pet store was a
female what did they do on sets to to to
get dogs to do that uh no it's 4th of
July I'm going to celebrate with my wife
take my time massage her make sure she
is fully satisfied that's the spirit man
ah no burn it like I said good guys need
a
break I know you'll do the right thing
this time oh PS your wife's rocking body
still drives me crazy stay out of the
astral plane above our
bedroom hey who wants to have a bill
fight and then HBO immediately said
watch something
else
wow oh nice and the New Radicals needle
drop for the very end the fun DVD menu
credits I like it I'm with it I'm I'm
about that it's good oh
man guys first and foremost if you're if
you're joining me here and now and uh
you happen to be listening on Apple or
Spotify go ahead and rate this hopefully
five stars but you know whatever you
feel uh just helps us you know spread
these round and grow the nation
reject um but yeah goodness I need a
second this is a fascinating experience
this and uh and certainly much more
Broad and developed than the Goosebumps
I saw Sophie Monk that's her name okay
yeah yeah oh and rert Gregson Williams
on the score a Rick Baker did the
special makeup effects okay not bad not
bad
interesting well all right before we go
any further uh one thing you know is
that this this video certainly had a
great many uh sponsors this this movie
you know had a lot of product placements
a lot of recognizable brand recognition
or that's that's repetitive but you get
what I mean and uh speaking of brand
recognition there are a couple people
who made this video possible and let's
cut to them right now thank you to
America's number one meal kid hellofresh
for partnering with us it's always great
to partner with people Who services you
actually use because as someone like me
who's always juggling a pack schedule
between filming and editing finding time
for healthy eating can be a challenge
that's where hellofresh has been a game
changer for my life with hellofresh I
get farm fresh pre-portioned ingredients
and delicious recipes delivered right to
my doorstep so I don't have to step
outside it's revolutionized my home
cooking experience making it not just
easy but super enjoyable and affordable
keyw I recently tried their delicious
barbecue pineapple flat RADS and their
zucchini pomodora Panet bake both for
mouth wateringly delicious and fit
perfectly with my pescatarian lifestyle
pescatarian s fancy and asking my
friends who love meat hellofresh has an
incredible variety tempts me to be a
meat eater again people I know I've
really recommended their lemon parsley
chicken palard I think is how you
pronounce it and the Fuego chicken fajo
tacos regardless hellofresh menu has
something for everyone but of course
it's not just about the food it's about
saving time too not having a waight in
line at a grocery store even self
checkouts on fast enough these days the
convenience of having everything
delivered pre-portioned right to your
door is Priceless especially with her
quick and easy meals like 15-minute
recipes spending less time in the
kitchen and more time doing what I love
which is filming and editing so here's
the deal if you want a great way to
support the channel and also support you
know having a new lifestyle healthy
affordable lifestyle in the year 2024 go
to hellofresh.com rejects free and use
code rejects free for free breakfast for
life you heard that right one breakfast
item per box while the subscription is
active free breakfast for Life for
hellofresh.com reex free use promo code
reject free try it out and let me know
your favorite dishes stay healthy and
let's keep enjoying those movies and
shows all right reject Nation let's get
real for a moment running this channel
is incredible but managing finances
especially taxes and budgeting both for
the channel and my personal life can be
overwhelming that's where rocket money
has been a financial Lifesaver for me
even before I ever partnered up with
them like I said I've been very
fortunate to be working with Brands
whose products I already use so it's a
win-win for him walk but it can be a
win-win for you too cuz there's a reason
I use them rocket money is a personal
finance app that simplifies managing
money by canceling unnecessary
subscriptions lowering bills and
crafting a budget that fits your
specific lifestyle for someone like me
who can easily lose track of expenses
throughout every single day of the month
it's been eye openening to see where I
was overspending stuff I don't use that
I kept paying for especially apps man I
was way too many apps rocket money does
the heavy lifting by analyzing your
spending then customizes notifications
to help you stay within your budget
goals it's not just about saving money
it's about actively seeing and feeling
your financial progress It's a great
feeling they track your monthly
subscriptions too so many free trials I
signed up for that I forgot to you know
get rid of before the free trial was
done making it super easy to cancel the
ones you don't use couple of clicks and
you're putting money back in your pocket
telling you have you ever found hidden
subscriptions or pay for services you
forgot about because Rocky money is a
huge asset in helping to uncover those
and even negotiate some of my bills down
to like 20% so if you're ready to take
control of your finances and there's no
better time than now because it is the
beginning of the year check out rocket
money and see how much you could be
saving stop wasting money on things you
do not use so to help support the
channel and help support your wallet
visit rocket money.com / rejects rocket
money currently has over 5 million users
and has helped save its members an
average of $720 a year with over $500
million in canceled subscriptions
they've helped me and I'm confident
they'll do the same for you that's
rocket money.com rejects your bank
account will thank you all right though
that was super fun I got to say you know
I mean there there are certainly
elements of Adam Sandler's humor that
aren't you know necessarily 100% my
flavor if I'm just going for you know
what I'm gravitated toward but uh but I
really enjoyed this experience and I and
I'd heard people say over the years that
it was you know like a surprisingly good
one or surprisingly affecting and I can
definitely see that here this got me a
little misty-eyed at a couple points
especially toward the end um and yeah
it's like you know I was saying earlier
this this reminds me of of I think it
was a Goosebumps or or something I mean
you know like the the idea of a remote
control that controls real life is not
you know the most crazy concept for a
bunch of people to arrive at
independently but but yeah like I I like
what this made out of that and the
cautionary tale that this became and the
way that it is essentially like a
scrooge Story by the end of it you know
you're seeing the error of your way
personified in the past in the present
in the future with slightly less of you
know the specific structure that that
has but yeah you have this otherworldly
Spirit who shows up here and there in
Christopher Watkin who I really enjoyed
as like sort of the you know the lead
not not not lead supporting character
cuz obviously you have a bunch of other
lead supporting character characters who
are more you know who share more screen
time who are like the prominent figures
in uh the Sandler characters life um but
yeah having him as this sort of main
sort of um I don't know this magical
character existing on the periphery
popping up every now and again like I
said it kind of reminded me of like Don
knots and Pleasantville the the TV
repair man but if he spent more time in
the movie uh than he does in that
particular film and yeah just like the
way he brought his unique walking uh I
thought was really well pitched and ATT
tuned because obviously you get
Christopher Walkin when you want
Christopher Walkin and in this movie
he's doing you know very much doing his
is walking his his timing it's specific
and uh and yeah he's doing he's leaning
into his unique Cadence and I think that
yeah with the look that they have him in
he's just this perfect you know um
Midway point between this Whimsical sort
of impish figure and plausibly you know
the spirit of death is essentially and
uh and I like that that's what it became
like I do appreciate when a movie
especially a movie like this any kind of
you know comedy that's going for a high
concept or something that does you know
uh uh bring with it sort of an innate
cautionary tale of some kind like I like
when we can shift over into you know
seriousness when it's appropriate for
the story when it's appropriate for the
action and and I thought this managed to
do that you know obviously there are so
many things and it's such an enticing
Concept in general there's so many
things that we would love to skip past
in life certainly like traffic being uh
you know like the the first rung of that
ladders I think everybody would be like
man if I could just fast forward the
traffic experience like you know that'd
be great uh you know especially when
you're sitting you're not going anywhere
like I like a drive but you know you get
what I mean and uh and yeah coming in
with the fun of the concept and you know
the promise of yeah idealizing your life
by skipping all the boring bits and
getting right to the good stuff or
getting right to the thing you've been
anticipating it's something that yeah
would entice anybody I think or most
people but could easily go wrong and
enhance your worst qualities and I think
that across the board they did a nice
job of of that you know at first like
the whole thing of getting to the remote
and the fact that they have like a
billion remotes around it did kind of
feel like a a bit of a random plot
thread to get us there like a mechanic
specifically designed to get us there
rather than you know a real part of the
story or part of the characterization
like the the the sweets and stuff the
the cakes and the Twinkies like that
felt more ingrained even though even
still that kind of felt like a like just
a I don't know it could have been
anything like it it does come back and
there are elements of like oh man you
know like you're really unhealthy and
you got fat or you know you had heart
attacks or whatever and you're like it
comes I think most into Focus as you
know a a real part of the you know array
of of things happening within the
character when it turns out that yeah
like his son has grown up you know to be
a heavier set guy or whatever that is
and and you know that it's probably
because of this mostly cake and sweets
based you know eating like it's a
miracle that the S of Sandler character
and and everyone around him doesn't have
like diabetes or something just because
it seems like all he eats are Twinkies
uh but yeah yeah yeah having these
different elements kind of come together
to inform you know along with the
obvious of he's really dedicated to his
work and he's always prioritizing that
over everything else and I thought they
did a nice job of drawing that portrait
as well uh because you know again there
are a lot of things that kind of recur
in some of these movies or or in you
know like Business Place comedy or or
movie about a guy who's consumed by work
and business you know and who needs to
you know take a step back and and
recognize the little things and the
important things about life and and to
honor the people around him not just
just you know the climb up the social
and or uh you know economic ladder and
all that stuff and yeah I thought they
personified that nicely and they did a
good job of starting out in a pretty
grounded place where yeah this guy is a
bit of a mess he's you know got at least
time management problems he's he's a bit
of a you know he's got clutter all
around and he's you know still holding
down this high level architect like it
is funny like I get what people are are
pointing out when they laugh about you
know these tropes of Adam Sandler movies
in that like yeah he's this schlubby
kind of wise ass dude who somehow
manages to have like the most gorgeous
wife ever always this time K back in
sale who I really liked in this too I
mean I I feel like those are characters
that can fall by the wayside or you know
not I mean it's not like she gets a
million moments to really explore this
character and you know really unpack her
life but as where this character is
positioned I thought she brought a lot
of just love lovely presence to it and I
really believed her and you've got to
you know kind of immediately love this
person and want to see the best for them
along with the kids kids are easier
because they're cute um but yeah you got
to really kind of feel for his family
and you got to be able to feel for her
when she's going through the different
you know trials that this dude presents
her kind of constantly and yeah the way
that sort of all that compiles the
transition into the Beyond section which
again like I thought that was it was fun
like I don't think they're trying too
hard to trick you like it's in the
editing it's in the way the the quality
of the picture changes when he rolls
over on the bed and the colors are a
little different the lighting's a little
different he goes into the Beyond
section and obviously it has this
heightened again everything's just
bigger on the inside you know like it's
clearly a bit Whimsical and Fantastical
and I don't think that they're really
trying
to they're I don't think they're trying
to sell it like it's not a dream I think
they're just counting on the fact that
you'll eventually forget about that and
I kind of did you know like eventually
they cut back and you're like okay yeah
that's right um but yeah I thought that
was a nice conceit and a good way to
again honor the fact that this is a bit
of a it's funny I just watched The Mask
which almost had this there are elements
of that in in a different way that were
reminding me or hearkening toward It's a
Wonderful Life and then here you know I
was thinking very much of of yeah some
kind of Scrooge scenario um and
especially again because it's this guy
who is there are a bunch of different
ways to do this but this takes the scope
of you know a guy
who is just dedicated to his business to
his job to a fault and again that's
something that I think is very relatable
where people are like I I just I got to
go hard on this because you know one
more one more one more and then we'll be
able to rest and then I'll have an
assistant who can handle half this stuff
and then we will have the time then we
will have the time later and that's a
really hard thing and like you know
being in an independent operation like a
YouTube channel often puts you into
positions like that and and we are lucky
enough here to be in positions where we
don't have to be as like you know
immediately on top of stuff and like
rushing around and like on call all the
time but there's still that you know
that persistent I think across life no
matter where you work or or you find
your you know living being made there is
that Hazard of you know worrying that
it's all going to go away and that you
know if you don't do what you're doing
now you're going to you know lose it all
or it's going to decrease or or uh you
know uh uh flail in some way because of
that you know I think that's a very easy
place to get to and and the fact that
you need to sacrifice and we live in a
culture that incentivizes you to
Priority that kind of equates all of
your worth and value into your job and
how productive you are and you know how
your ability to pay for things and
conduct money efficiently you know like
it's it is the irony of like any piece
of especially big scale corporate art
telling you to you know step back look
at what's important be with your family
when this is in and of itself like a
giant product that you know a bunch of
people probably worked insane hours to
make so like there's a ton of irony in
these kinds of stories or or like a
Christopher Robin came to mind early on
in the movie and that's another one of
those where it's like thanks Disney like
like it it works in isolation I like
that movie even but yeah it's always
that funny thing of like okay massive
business Corp who like half of this half
of these characters basically are the
people working in places like that who
aren't taking this advice but that also
are putting out a movie with this
message you know it's it's kind of fun
and ironic but um but yeah I I liked the
overall cast and there like so many
recognizable faces I feel like we're
getting to that point this is like 2006
right so we're getting to that point
past that early Heyday of like you know
Sandler joints when he was probably what
fresh off the SNL cast now we're more
into like well- ingrained Adam Sandler
big screen presence uh you know again
we're solidifying the tropes of the Adam
Sandler movie and I like some of those
things and other of those things you
know you feel the kind of the wear and
the stretch marks of time you know
moments where you're like okay this this
hasn't maybe aged quite as well or this
sensibility maybe doesn't fly as uh
brazenly as it does you know in a in a
Time such as this you know that stuff
doesn't fly as much now you know you get
to the the harassment seminar I was like
oh God what way is this going to go and
you know it's relatively innocuous but
it is still kind of like different from
the sensibility with which we approach
those things these days um and you know
you have like the Rachel Dr character
transitioning into being man uh which
thankfully the movie doesn't spend too
much time on and isn't too disrespectful
about even though it is ultimately
played for a joke and it is supposed to
be some kind of like what is happening
kind of thing um but also it's not so
much that you can't just be like well
maybe she's maybe he's happier like this
and and we're good at that you know
we're good with that I don't know like
yeah I don't that's me filling in the
blank more than it is the movie so and
and just the the you know barrage of
like you know oh we got all these sexy
assistants around and you know women be
throwing themselves at Adam Sandler and
and and the wife's sister is you know
she just sleeping with everybody's
brother you know like there there are
certain things like that that are uh you
know a bit crude and a bit maybe less
socially enlightened than we like to be
these days um and you know they are what
they are you can't change them now in
the past can't click that remote and go
back but as far as those elements go
those elements that usually kind of turn
me off the more crude and crass and the
more not to not to you know I don't want
to launch a war in the comments but you
know the humor that skews more
misogynists certainly uh maybe not in
like a mean or malicious way but
certainly plays into those stereotypes
you know those elements are here I don't
love them but they also didn't wreck the
overall impact of the movie and the
scenes that really do have their heart
in a good place and you know for again
that slacker you know almost Stoner kind
of person you know I could see this
being very touching as well you know
this kind of speaks broad if you can tap
into it for some of us if you can see
past the crudeness or if the crudeness
is your inroad either way you're kind of
winding up at the message at the end and
and the movie giving again way to the
more um just thoughtful and you know
harder hitting themes uh yeah I I liked
the Journey of that going from yeah this
fun innocuous slacker comedy ooh fantasy
element we got this remote that could do
everything but then slowly it's you know
reading your mind and and again
enhancing and amplifying your uh you
know your your core Tendencies your ID
almost and you know in doing so it's
highlighting the way in which yeah like
a lot you know we all go on autopilot we
all want to check out of certain things
and it's basically telling you that you
should be present for every and yeah at
the end that culminates in good things
fun things you know he wants to tell his
uh parents that he loves them he wants
to spend that time with the kids and the
family you know um but two I mean it's
it's also about yeah you got to take the
showers and sit in the traffic and have
the arguments and freaking give them
Mass everybody's so averse to giving
massages and and like warming things up
in the bedroom and I'm like why guys
like geez again and it's part of the the
the goofiness of the of the plot and all
that but I feel like you know I don't
yeah it's just like you're trying to
fast forward through this part to get to
the already you know the the briefest
most good part I guess to you but also
yeah I don't know I'm just like how did
you guys like is this always like
there's that whole frequent joke of like
oh it's so short you know and I'm like
but was it ever long if this is your
attit anyway uh yeah and then those
things slowly picking up to the point
where it's like oh I can't stop it the
thing is anticipating uh my thoughts and
my you know inclinations and it knows
what I want to skip and and you know
life can feel that way like it's like
time is outside your control certainly
and that you know it's rocketing by and
you're blinking and you're waking up you
know many months later and you know
obviously not one to one you've got all
your memories you know you're there
every day and there's a mundanity that
comes with that but it is possible like
time is a tricky and a strange thing and
it moves fast and slow all at once and
uh and I thought this in in more subtle
ways kind spoke to that and it's this
the fear the horror element that kind of
sets in over time as you're like oh my
God you know I don't have control over
this now you know there are lapses in my
memory and I'm sort of coming to and and
you know it's almost like you're it's
almost like the story of someone
disassociating if you removed the Sci-Fi
element of you know the remote and all
the fun stuff like I thought it was
really fun what they did with the you
know like the construct and and checking
in on the rules and like okay so you're
kind of in an autopilot like a really
lowgrade autopilot when you're fast
forwarding or skipping chapters and I
mean I guess it's lucky that you know
this guy's paths that that he was on in
autopilot basically led him to like huge
you know again economic success um but
it does it is just like a funny thing to
me I'm I'm like okay interesting like
you know because it could go so wrong in
so many ways on autopilot when you're
skipping ahead like I I have to imagine
it's like he he thinks about what he
wants and he gets there so it's also a
manifestation mie uh but but you know
like what if you got 3 years later to
the point you thought you'd get your
promotion and find yourself like out on
the street or something you know but but
those are things that I wasn't really
thinking about during the movie and
those are just things that yeah you you
can Muse about within the high concept
of it you know but for again a high
concept comedy like this that a doesn't
have to get very emotional if it doesn't
want to and B doesn't have to develop
the scii you know doesn't have to
develop the high concept doesn't have to
develop the rules of the world or
whatever I thought they did a fun job of
paying attention to those things and you
know playing with time subtly so that
you know when you're further into his
life you know the set designs are really
different and you're in like a future
hospital at the end and like the hair uh
cuts are changing and the outfits are
changing and getting more you know sort
of out there and more futurized and
everything and the makeups too like
there are old age makeups there are
younger age makeups for some of the
older actors I thought all that stuff
was nice uh you know the the fat suits
like again for for some of the more uh
Progressive and
inclusive uh conversations we have you
know developed in our culture you know
since this came out you know like it's
you know you're you're using that the
the bigger body for a punchline which is
kind of a drag but it also does factor
into the story to some degree again like
those are things that if you really
wanted to like flesh those threads out
and be like oh man like you know this
again Adam Sandler is able to like skate
through this movie having like a fine
enough physique whilst also like always
eating candy so like I was like if you
done this maybe a little more gradually
but you know again there's that effect
of like well when he wakes up that way
and it's like totally foreign you know
like I I get the choices they made here
if it was my movie I might have uh you
know finessed them a little better or um
I don't know just done it in a way that
doesn't punch down quite as hard um but
you know again for for the sensibility
of what this is it's not to be
unexpected really and I thought that
yeah the the the greater Strokes of the
movie and you know the message behind it
and just the way that it's characterized
and The Ensemble they drew together was
quite charming and yeah by the end like
this did transcend from being just a fun
Whimsical uh again sort of uh off uh not
off the cuff but but yeah that sort of
like um what is I don't know what to
call that demeanor but that you know
that ribbing sort of demeanor that sort
of uh that very um like big brother kind
of noie demeanor where like yeah you
know like it it's it's busting a lot of
balls and stuff like that but I bought
the you know actual sentimental side and
I feel like we're also kind of
witnessing that transition from you know
more broad comedy for Sandler into you
know starting to to play with drama
because you know when you get to the end
there again like when he's uh saying
when he's replaying the moment of his
father saying I love you son and and you
know looking at him that way and even
when uh he's got the the bit later on
uh or no no it's just before that with
with his son but but then yeah later on
when he wants you know his son not to
make the mistakes that he did and and
you know to go on the honeymoon instead
of staying back and working on this
project that's in shambles or whatever
you know like those moments I bought the
commitment and the emotion and all that
too and so like the sweet things that
are supposed to tug at your heartstrings
ultimately work and so do the cautionary
things and I think that's I I'm starting
to see that that's kind of the magic
when it's working of an Adam Sandler
movie you know it's the heart that
arises despite you know the more
abrasive parts of the main character
often attitude um sometimes it's
characters around them like if you're
watching the water boy or something like
that you know um Bobby buet is like a he
a very endearing and sweet character
whereas I'm more used to seeing Adam
Sandler play guys like this who are
again a bit of a wise ass and who are
you know real ball busters and stuff
like that you know he's a kind of a GU
guy uh so yeah like
those elements are here and sometimes
they're funny uh and the rest of it you
know it I don't know it's it's attuned
well enough that when you suspend
disbelief for you know what we know as
the Sandler verse kind of uh yeah like
this is an example of a movie that I
thought tied together quite nicely and
that worked and that you know showcased
a good amount of heart and a thoughtful
story I could tell like again I I I
hesitate to say that Adam Sandler I I
hesitate T to use the word mature or
maturing maturity but it does have a
more mature quality to it or it's
aspiring to something more mature uh you
know whilst also having like a bunch of
humping dog jokes and stuff like that
but you know uh again for what this is
and for who it's playing to you know
this it's again the kind of Comedy that
I don't put at the top of my taste scale
but at the same time I can tap into when
it's good and when again there are you
know other elements around be they good
casting an interesting concept some
heart uh again a little bit of you know
World weariness or whatever that is and
I thought this tied together very nicely
into all of that while also taking time
to have a a good sense of Attunement
with its fantasy and yeah I found it
overall to be really fun and Charming so
uh those are my thoughts on click uh let
me know your thoughts as well good
soundtrack on this too um and yeah a lot
of nice little character beats in
between the the more Broad and and crass
elements so uh so yeah I think there's a
lot for a lot of different people to
grab from this and again just a great
High concept jumping off point in the
universal remote and all that stuff uh
so yeah that's what I got for now leave
me your thoughts down below stay tuned
for whatever comes next leave me
whatever other Adam Sandler joins you
want uh one or any of us to check out
and uh yeah we'll catch you on the next
one much love for now people and uh
cheers